facebook gründer mark zuckerberg will
künstliche intelligenz bei sich zuhause
einführen und stephen hawking warm vor
den gefahren
es klingt wie in einem
science-fiction-film
aber facebook gründer mark zuckerberg
will die technik der zukunft bei sich
zuhause realität werden lassen auf
facebook veröffentlichte er jetzt seine
vorstellungen von einer künstlichen
intelligenz welche er mit der aus
aktuellen kino blockbustern vergleich
zitat you think of it kein of love is in
iron man die ki soll ähnlich wie tony
starks gehilfe sein ganzes haus
automatisieren zum beispiel die
temperaturregulierung oder die
musikwiedergabe sie soll aber auch das
zimmer seiner tochter rund um die uhr
abrufbar machen freunde und verwandte
via gesichtserkennung ins haus lassen
und außerdem soll die ki ihn bei seiner
arbeit unterstützen zitat und works
little help me visual eisbecher in bar
zu herbert becker services and lead me
organisation small effekte fli zu
deutsch die ki soll dabei helfen daten
in der virtuellen realität zu
visualisieren um bessere services
bereitzustellen und um ihm zu
ermöglichen
seine organisation besser zu führen
zuckerberg sieht das projekt als seinen
persönlichen vorsatz für das jahr 2016
haben genauer gesagt er möchte das für
sich selbst verwirklichen
marktwirtschaftliche zukunftspläne
spricht er nicht an
an seinem vorsatz teilhaben zu lassen
möchte er die welt dennoch zitat einem
looking forward to share with all over
the course of the year zuckerberg testet
also quasi für uns und was er dann mit
uns teilen wird könnte zeigen in welche
richtung sich künstliche intelligenz für
unseren alltag entwickeln wird die
erforschung der künstlichen intelligenz
oder auch artificial intelligence kurz
hat sich auch der schon in den letzten
videos häufig erwähnte unternehmer allen
masc auf die fahne geschrieben er und
ein paar weitere geschäftsleute haben
open gegründet ihr gemeinsamer wunsch
ist es zitat digitale intelligenz so zu
erweitern dass die gesamte menschheit
davon profitieren kann unabhängig von
der verpflichtung gewinne zu
erwirtschaften so greg goodman ceo der
op und ilias kiefer wissenschaftlicher
leiter ob mai
eine so genannte non profit organisation
kurz mpu außerdem gewinn für die
wissenschaft gibt es keine
wirtschaftliche gewinnabsicht rund eine
milliarde us-dollar beträgt das
startkapital der ngo und wer hatte alles
investiert ihre maske der auch paypal
space ex und tesla motors gewundert hat
reid hoffmann gründer von linkedin peter
thiel ein investor aus deutschland sie
haben das geld in das projekt gesteckt
außerdem gab es noch geld von amazon web
services infosys und von der
non-profit-organisation weiß research
allerdings gibt es auch kritische
stimmen wenn es um die weiterentwicklung
künstlicher intelligenz geht der
physiker stephen hawking warnt vor ihnen
zitat eine super intelligente künstliche
intelligenz wird extrem gut in der
erfüllung ihrer ziele seien und wenn
diese ziele nicht mit unseren
übereinstimmen haben wir ein problem
zitat ende
gefährlich wird die künstliche
intelligenz laut rocking also erst wenn
menschen nicht in ihren effizienz plan
passen wenn der mensch das unproduktive
glied in einer kette ist sollten wir die
weiterentwicklung von künstlichen
intelligenzen dann überhaupt noch
erlauben was ist eure meinung dazu
ich bin gespannt diskutiertes in den
kommentaren ansonsten abonnieren nicht
vergessen kostet ja nix das nächste
video schauen und ein like für dieses
video da würde ich mich tierisch darüber
freuen ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran